today on the matt wall show the number
one song in the world right now consists
of a couple of women
shouting about their genitals and we're
told that this is empowering and sex
positive and inspiring but
in fact it is of course the opposite and
all of the people defending and
celebrating the song
are hypocrites and i'll explain why also
five headlines including
another blm supporter pulls a gun on a
motorist who committed the crime of
trying to drive on a public road
and in our daily cancellation i will
cancel the climate alarmists
who have scared children so much that
now some kids according to the daily
mail anyway are
traumatized when they go outside all of
that on the way but first
um listen this is this is simple as far
as i am concerned everyone
absolutely everyone needs a vpn to
protect them
if you're using the internet without one
you're being needlessly
reckless so get with the program get
expressvpn in fact
but just think about censorship on
social media sites the left wants to
silence and remove any voices they don't
agree with twitter for example
was supposed to be an open platform um i
don't need their content moderators
acting like the op-ed section the new
york times
so instead of letting social media sites
revoke your
right to free speech how about revoking
their right to your data
i think maybe that's what we should be
doing instead now you could just
deactivate all your social media
accounts but
problem is you know that would be giving
the left just what they want in the
first place instead
instead of doing that of retreating i
take
actual steps to protect myself i use
expressvpn ever wondered
how free to access social media sites
make all their money well
by tracking your searches your video
history everything you click on and then
selling
um your valuable data when you use
expressvpn
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address
that's
you know the basics of how it works it's
pretty simple really and that makes your
activity
more difficult to trace and also more
difficult to sell to advertisers because
they have no right to be doing that
anyway this is your information your
data
and expressvpn couldn't be easier um to
set up you just tap one button on your
phone your computer
and you're protected expressvpn also
encrypts 100
of your data to protect you from hackers
and
internet bad guys look it's just always
a good idea to protect yourself
on the internet there's no reason not to
there's no downside so
um it's finally time to say no to
censorship and take back your online
privacy at expressvpn.com
walsh by visiting my special link you'll
get an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free again that's
expressvpn.comr essvpn.com
walsh
walls to expressvpn.com your data today
okay uh let's uh
let's let's get into this now
many people in the culture are intensely
focused on rooting out
problematic language and toxic messages
they insist that we must
rename sports teams and objects in outer
space
and uh and rebrand grocery items and ban
books and censor films all for the sake
of protecting society from the harm that
inappropriate words and ideas may cause
anyone who steps outside the perceived
lines of decency is condemned with a
hostility that we once reserved only for
rapists and murderers it would be quite
confusing then
for any alien who lands on this planet
or any person who emerges after being
lost in the rainforest for the past five
decades to discover
just what sort of media these
perpetually scandalized damsels in
distress
enjoy because the very same people who
were so traumatized by a fast food ceo's
comments that they boycotted his chicken
restaurant for eight years
and the very same people who have
tearfully denounced offensive disney
costumes worn by children
and the very same people who are liable
to break into convulsions of anger if
you say something really provocative
like
men have penises and the very same
people who invented concepts like
trigger warnings and safe spaces
are the ones who will listen to
appreciate and celebrate
the most vulgar and degrading television
shows films and songs made by some of
the most
loathsome and repulsive people this
country has ever produced
they are puritans about all that is
innocuous and libertines about
all that is genuinely objectionable they
have in a word
everything backwards and never has that
contrast been clearer than with the
reaction to
the latest bit of audible sewage from
the rapper
cardi b now before we get into the song
we should note that cardi b
a former stripper has admitted publicly
that she used to drug and take advantage
of men
um in her own words in fact listen to
this
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
because they do not know
a real scholar there that we have on our
hands cardi b cosby's a weak excuse for
this behavior is that she had to do it
to survive
yet she has elsewhere brag that she made
up to three thousand dollars a night as
a stripper and had thirty five thousand
dollars in singles saved by the time
she turned 22 cc irs for comparison sake
a surgeon earns a route 120
an hour which means that cardi b by her
own testimony was taking in
substantially more than a surgeon just
by taking off her clothes and yet she
needed to lure men back to hotel room
drug them and rob them in order to stave
off starvation
somehow the story doesn't add up it
would seem that she is simply a
sociopath and a predator who enjoys
preying upon
other human beings like bill cosby who
also drugged people and took advantage
of them
but this fact does not seem to have
troubled reebok or pepsi who have both
signed million dollar endorsements with
the confessed criminal
the cancel culture has has ruined
people's lives over edgy tweets they
posted as teenagers
yet cardi b cosby's personal history
involves drugging people and taking
advantage of them and she admits to it
and brags about it and faces absolutely
no consequence for it whatever
white privilege tends to manifest itself
and rather
unexpected ways these days you might say
now
cardi's newest song topping the charts
in the u.s the uk across the world
is called wap it's an acronym that i
can't spell out on the air but
uh which references female genitalia in
fact i can't repeat any of the lyrics on
the air but suffice it to say that the
song begins and ends with the refrain
there's some [ __ ] in this house and
everything that happens in between
would seem very much to confirm the the
those declarations the song wants to be
extraordinarily vulgar and it succeeds
it also wants to be shocking but in that
regard it fails
for an artist to be truly shocking she
must have wit
and intelligence and vision there is a
severe scarcity of those qualities among
any of the people involved in this song
so
they're reduced to being merely
obnoxious instead
the entire song is like something that
someone might have scrawled in red ink
on a bathroom stall in fact i think that
a bathroom stall may have a writing
credit on this song but i can't be sure
the problem is is less with the music
itself
or the video accompanying it than with
the reaction to it
in saner times if women were rolling
around on the floor and screaming about
their genitals for three and a half
minutes
we would just ignore them or perhaps
refer them to a counselor who
specializes
in that particular form of mania but we
don't live insane times and so a song
with a generic beat mediocre production
qualities and semi-coherent lyrics
encouraging women to make prostitutes of
themselves
is celebrated as according to the new
york times or the la times rather
a sex-positive triumph and according to
usa today
an anthem of female fierceness
um and it gets even more absurd than
that there's an article
on a website called complex which hails
wap
as a great cultural achievement
and it just goes into great detail
talking about
about this work it exclaims in part [ __ ]
is the epitome of female empowerment
both both cardi and megan
the other uh artists use the term
loosely on the track
are powerhouses of female sexuality
independence and dominance in a
male-dominated genre that is often
criticized for misogynistic wordplay
towards women
the two rappers have never shied away
from taking back the narrative of
femininity and hip-hop
and during a time when black women have
taken to social media to advocate for
their protection
and support while basking in their
blackness the music video
couldn't be more timely continues on
later walking in the footsteps of iconic
sex positive female rappers
like trina lil kim and kia kaya
cardi and megan splash around in a pool
of water which we can assure you
which we can assume is symbolism for yup
and describe in detail what a night in
bed with them might be like
uh though through cocky self-assured
lyrics the duo
own their sexuality and shine light on
other prominent sex symbols and female
musicians
um and then it continues on later
wap is a prime example of progressive
womanhood and modern femininity
the theme of women prioritizing pleasure
and joy runs from start to finish
liberation and power are showcased in
lyrics placing the track as the duo's
most forward and
compelling expression also the song
slaps
okay many other articles have been
written
to inform us predictably that any
criticism of this song is misogynistic
and racist and all the other is and isms
and this is the real danger there has
always been stupid degraded vulgarity in
the world but it becomes especially to
use the favorite term of gender studies
majors
problematic when the degradation is
presented to
our children as something to aspire to
so that's the issue here self-debasement
is not empowering and it is rather
important that we make this point even
if it does provide the people who are
recently offended by a can of beans an
opportunity to call someone else a
snowflake for a change
but the difference between this
criticism that i'm making right now and
leftist snowflakery
is that the criticism here is warranted
and the message being criticized
is actually harmful young girls are
being
explicitly encouraged by this song and
by so much else in pop culture
to embrace their own objectification to
offer themselves up to be used by men
who see them as nothing more than a
masturbatory device
they're being told to choose emptiness
over joy and to see stupidity and
crassness as
feminine and the frauds who cheer this
on and to help to
and help to usher a generation of girls
into a miserable life of whorishness and
loneliness
will soon revert back to decrying the
objectification of the female form and
pinning the blame
for that on the patriarchy and other
phantoms
the point here is that even the people
actively promoting the objectification
of women
and the commodification of sexuality
know very well that the
the harm that it causes and will tell
you that
if you catch them on a day when they're
pretending to care about it
now i want you to consider
uh just to further illustrate this the
words of a woman
by the name of suki hana who appeared in
the [ __ ] music video
and later joined cardi in the gang for a
discussion promoted and broadcast by
apple music
here's what she had to say listen to
this i feel like
being like sexual like
honestly not wrong that cuz baby i got
three kids and i mean i got these kids
from
at the end of the day me being a whole
like these people say
like honestly i liberate a lot of a lot
of hoes
you feel me when i hear cardi talk about
popping some me and my is witty like we
that liberate us because it's like [ __ ]
you self-respect is hoes
how y'all got self-respect like i don't
think y'all got self-respect like that
cause first of all
you supposed to tax these that
self-respect
you feel me like i just it make me feel
liberated like i love crossing
boundaries
because guess what scare money don't
make no money if you gonna be scared to
get that money you won't be scared to be
yourself
and say this who i am then you ain't
gonna get that coin like that
thanks leaving aside the the the
fingernails there that must make it
impossible for her to eat a cheeto
without blinding herself notice the
question she poses
how y'all got self-respect she asks she
quite literally doesn't even
understand the concept of self-respect
she goes from
recoiling at the very idea that a woman
would respect herself to suggesting that
true self-respect is to be found in the
payments
a man renders after having sex with you
need i explain the problem here people
pay for goods and services to get paid
for your sexuality is to have it treated
with the same reverence that one affords
a hamburger
or an oil change you have reduced
yourself
your body your very person to a
commodity and offered it to someone who
doesn't care about you
certainly doesn't love you and sees you
only as a means to an
end this is the diametric opposite of
self-respect
why do you think drug abuse and suicide
are so common among prostitutes
reducing yourself to the sum total of
your body parts is not a path to a
healthy life or
or a long one we should note it is a
road to disappointment and despair and
death
where the fun for whatever it's worth is
sure to dissipate when your physical
beauty wears away
if not long before this is the road that
cardi b
her fellow pop stars and her insidious
cheerleaders in the media would like
your daughter to walk down
and as a man with two daughters
i have no shame or hesitation in saying
to these forces
no and go to hell
i'm sorry that you didn't have a father
who loved you but my daughters do and so
they're gonna know better
you can go wallow in your own filth and
misery all you want i will make sure
that my girls do not follow you there
let's go to five headlines
[Music]
okay and here's a another one of these
the daily wire reports a black lives
matter protester allegedly pulled a gun
on a truck in indianapolis
indianapolis late last week as the truck
tried to get around a group of
protesters that were occupying the road
a video of the incident went viral on
social media over the weekend
but the incident appears to have
happened last thursday here's the video
get that baby
[Music]
come on buddy don't be stupid
what you have to understand here is that
these leftist
quote-unquote protesters they
have been driven so mad by their own
sense of entitlement
they have gone so crazy with entitlement
that they they really at this point
don't even understand
uh the concept of they they stand in the
middle of the road with a gun and
pointed out a
at a driver they really think they have
a right to do that
they they really i believe that they
actually believe they have a right to do
it
which is why if you ever say to them you
know you're not supposed to do it what
do you mean
what do you mean i can't do this this is
this this is this is freedom
stop being a fascist they really don't
get it
because as i said they have quite
literally been driven mad by their sense
of entitlement number two um speaking of
madness report in the ap
says riverdale nursing home in the bronx
appears on paper to have escaped the
worst of the chronovirus pandemic with
an official count
of just four deaths in its 146 bed
facility
the truth according to the home is far
worse 21 dead
most transported to hospitals before
they succumbed
it was a cascading effect administrator
emily um
fuziov recalled one after the other new
york's coronavirus death toll
in nursing homes already among the
highest in the nation could actually be
a significant undercount
unlike every other state with major
outbreaks new york only counts residents
who died on nursing home property and
not those who were transported to
hospitals and died there
the statistic could add thousands to the
state's official care
care home death toll of just 6 600 but
so far the administration
of democratic governor andrew cuomo has
refused to divulge the number leading to
speculation that the state is
manipulating the figures
to make it appear it is doing a better
uh better job than other states
and um making a tragic situation less
dire so this
is i mean uh nothing to see here
just you know we start with government
policies that directly killed thousands
and now we go to a an actual conspiracy
to cover up how bad the damage is
and governor cuomo is just sailing
through this no problem at all
no problem at all for him
you know that's that's democratic
privilege for you number three my
personal favorite
musical artist kashi69 uh a poet and
musician even more brilliant and
insightful in cardi b if you can believe
it
is causing controversy today not because
of his lyrics or because he's a
convicted violent felon who only escaped
a half century in prison because
he turned around and snitched on the
other gang members and his crew
not because of that but because he wrote
a subway without a mask
[Music]
watch
this is
just shocking behavior there shocking
but and this is what people are upset
about
uh and it goes back to what i what i
said at the top about
even though you know if you criticize
pop music or whatever
it is that takashi six nine does
you're always going to be you're gonna
have people scoffing at you and saying
oh just
just relax it's just it's just music you
snowflake
yet these are the people that are
offended by everything in this case
they're offended by a guy
because he's not wearing a mask on the
subway um and
and and i i didn't even mention in the
cardi b song
actually there has been some leftist
backlash against the song it's got
nothing to do with
the celebration of the objectification
of women
um it's two reasons number one kylie
jenner is in the song
and that's a controversy i have no idea
why i think it's just it's literally
just because she's white
so there are people that are upset that
a white person is in the song
and also that there's tigers there are
uh big cats
and and so and so um uh you know the
tiger
carol baskin chimed in and other animal
rights people have been offended but so
those are the two things we're
we're worried about we're worried about
the tigers and we're worried that uh
a white person was allowed in in the
video because you can't you can't have
any of that
okay number four the huffington post
reports a washington man was arrested on
saturday for allegedly assaulting a 72
year old veteran over a face mask
dispute
police apprehended cody hansen 35
at his home after he was reported the
july 18th incident left the unidentified
victim with a broken jaw and cornea
abrasion
and uh what happened is a partially
disabled
elderly veteran and he was they were
looks like they were at a hotel yeah
okay they were in the lobby of hotel
the the elderly man says something to
hansen's girlfriend because she wasn't
wearing a face mask and then hanson
later returns
and does this if you ever had any if you
had any hope or optimism
about humanity's chances in general or
its chances of surviving some sort of
apocalyptic
situation rebuilding society if you had
any hope about that
it should be gone now uh just based on
this mask stuff
i mean really on on both sides just the
way people are acting
violently assaulting each other over
wearing a mask or not wearing one
it's total lunacy number five um
well we've talked a lot about lunacy
let's go to a little a little
a little gleaming light just a small bit
of a bit of sanity
uh it's a small matter but i think we
have to i tend to latch on to any sanity
that i see now
and because i got to find hope somewhere
so this is from uh deadline
reports the simpsons actor harry shearer
who gives voice to characters ranging
from elderly miser mr burns to the
unflappable of african-american
physician dr julius
hibbert isn't quite in agreement with
the long-running shows this
recent decision to stop using white
actors for non-white characters
shearer this is what he said in an
interview on times radio
i have a very simple belief about acting
the job of the actor is to play someone
who they're not
wow that's a provocative that's
provocative these days
to just define what acting is is is
provocative and controversial and
actually
not everyone agrees a lot of people
don't agree the issue has been the
source of debate with regard to fox
is uh fox is the simpsons since
um the documentary the problem with a
poo and last year's
announcement by hank azaria that a pus
who's portrays that he's going to step
away from the role
um though shira pointed out that he was
not opining on whether the producer's
recent decision was a mistake
he says that you know playing a range of
characters is the gig that's the job
description he continues i think there's
a conflation between representation
which is important
um shares suggests that he disagreed
with conflation between representation
and performance
people from all backgrounds should be
represented in the writing and producing
end of the business
so they help decide what stories to tell
and with uh what knowledge
but he adds again the job is playing
someone i'm not
and this this is there's there's nothing
to disagree with here it's
really basic common sense this is what
an actor does you pretend to be
something
that you're not but this is where we are
in our culture right now where
even this is an actor saying
my job is to pretend to be something i'm
not and this this is headline news
these days all right let's get to our
daily cancellation before we do
i want to tell you guys about the most
exclusive membership here over the daily
wire which is all access all access
members get to join all access live
our exclusive live stream uh q and a's
hosted every night by each of the hosts
i did one last night
all active memberships also feature
exclusive access to live online
discussions with our hosts writers and
special guests
you also get not one but two leftist
tears tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to a new daily wired product so
you get all of that go to dailywire.com
walsh right now to get 20 off all access
with coupon code access
that's dailywire.com walsh coupon code
access
for 20 off now for our daily
cancellation we're going to cancel
climate alarmists
uh but i want to be specific here
because frankly if you and the privacy
of your own home tremble in fear of the
day when the ice caps melt and you're
washed away by the tidal wave
that's your concern we all have our our
own irrational fears
uh mine is that i'll get into an
elevator and it will explode out of the
top of the building and i'll end up in
outer space
it's been known to happen folks okay
don't laugh it can happen it's science
but the point is we all have our fears
that we cherish and hold dear
uh and and that's okay okay i wouldn't
want to deprive you of that
what is not okay is when you impose
those fears on children
that's when i step in and issue fervent
cancellations
and that brings us to this daily mail
article and the headline is
some children find spending time in
nature distressing
because it can trigger feelings of
anxiety and despair linked to climate
change
the article says while most children
benefit from having
having time outdoors for some youngsters
it is triggering feelings of anxiety and
despair
due to fears over climate change these
troubling emotions and their link to
climate change have been studied by
university of columbia researchers for
their
for the british ecological society in
the first of its uh
kind study to focus on children and
teenagers connecting with nature the
team conducted a full review of other
studies articles and books
um and they they were trying to find out
you know how
how children are how the climate change
message is resonating with children
children and teenagers were triggered by
the natural world
and their inability to control what was
happening to the unraveling biosphere
according to the
to the team nothing wrong with that
children being triggered by the natural
world that's that's perfectly natural
right nothing to be concerned about the
authors found that measures currently
used to connect children to the natural
world can help others
cope with feelings of fear linked to
climate change
many children know they are inheriting a
changing world that is likely to get
worse
and this leads them to feelings of
anxiety and despair okay
let me uh say if
if your child even knows what the phrase
unraveling biosphere means much less
actively worries about it you are doing
something terribly wrong as a parent
a child should not spend any time
worrying about any sort
of doomsday scenario especially ones
that are as far-fetched and absurd as
the climate change apocalypse
even if it was even if it was true even
if the world really did teeter on the
brink of ecological disaster
why would you tell your kid about it
what can he do with the information how
can he solve it
what do you want your 11 year old to do
to fix the weather
if the answer is nothing then leave him
alone and let him have a childhood you
absolute maniac now there are other
more plausible and likely armageddons
potentially on the horizon
a solar flare could knock out all of our
communication send us back to the stone
age
a super volcano could erupt any time
blot out the sun kill our crops starve
us to death i mean it could happen
there could be an attack on the power
grid there could be a nuclear holocaust
there could be another pandemic perhaps
a
one that's bioengineered with a 50
mortality rate who knows hell we could
be invaded by aliens the pentagon seems
to be worried about that
anything could happen some more likely
than others
and whatever does happen or doesn't
it it almost is irrelevant on an
individual level anyway because we're
all doomed regardless
no matter what happens you have a death
sentence and you will not live very long
in the grand scheme i hate to tell you
the earth 2 is on death row the sun will
burn out eventually and in fact before
that happens probably the milky way
galaxy
is going to collide with the andromeda
galaxy and that will probably
not bode well for our little solar
system over here now it's 4 billion
years in the future but still
no matter what you will die
everyone you know will die everything
you've ever seen or touched in every
piece of ground you've ever tread upon
will be annihilated all of this is true
but you know what i don't tell my kids
that
why because it's not their job to worry
about that stuff right now
their job is to have fun to run around
to play to clean their room do their
lessons clean up their plates after
dinner
all of that sort of thing that's what i
want them worried about that's what
they're
those are their objectives throughout
the day it's not fair to saddle children
with far-fetched anxieties or even not
so far-fetched anxieties
but this is done for a reason of course
and the reason is sinister
there is no better tool for manipulation
than fear and there's no easier group of
people to scare than kids and so
the climate alarmists prey upon kids
condition them
brainwash them while they're vulnerable
and their minds are malleable
that's what this is really about and
that is why
the fear mongers are canceled
cancelled once again with a vengeance
as all of my cancellations uh are
performed
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
the show everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20. president trump considers accepting
the gop nomination
at gettysburg a teacher is terrified
that digital learning is going to allow
parents to hear what he is teaching
their children and surprise surprise it
turns out that some masks
not only don't help stop coronavirus
they actually make the spread worse
check it out on the michael knowles show